[موسيقى]
يعد مشروع داريا مشروعًا مثيرًا للغاية
لأنه مبنى يقع
داخل العاصمة الرياض ، ما
حدث على مدار الاثني عشر شهرًا الماضية كان
مثيرًا للغاية حيث كان هناك مشروع ضخم
بأصول مفتوحة لذلك مع
موقع اليونسكو للتراث العالمي مفتوح للعالم  افتتحنا أيضًا
في نهاية العام الماضي في
نفس الوقت منطقة Abrageri Terrace الراقية لتناول الطعام
والزيارة التي
تلت ذلك كانت رائعة للغاية ، حيث
نرى المزيد من أراضي وادي حنيثة الخضراء الخاصة بنا
تفتح للجمهور أيضًا بالإضافة
إلى  أن لدينا هذه
الفنون المستقبلية ، لذا فهي موجة تلو الأخرى
حيث تبدأ في رؤية تلك المدينة
تنبض بالحياة
عندما تنظر إلى الوراء في أي مكان في العالم
حول الطريقة التي اعتدت أن تفعل بها الأشياء ، يمكنك
أخذ دروس للمستقبل وهذا هو
بالضبط ما  لقد فعلنا ذلك ، لقد نظرنا في
كيفية استخدام بناء الطوب اللبن
وقمنا بتطبيقه باستخدام التكنولوجيا
والمدينة المستقبلية والتنمية الحضرية
عندما تأخذ
تركيزًا ذكيًا على المدينة الذكية عندما تفكر في ما
جعلها ذكية في  فيما مضى كيف
تفاعلنا كمجتمع ، كيف تفاعلنا مع
كيفية مشاركتنا في الموارد وكيف حصلنا على مصادر
محلية ، هذه كلها أشياء تحتل مكانة
عالية حقًا في قائمة أبطال
الاستدامة في جميع أنحاء العالم ،
وبالتالي فهذه المزيد من الدروس التي
يمكننا تعلمها من هويتنا.  في الماضي ، كانت
المساهمات الأجنبية في رؤية 2030
كبيرة حقًا وهي ملموسة حقًا
يمكننا رؤيتها بوضوح لأننا
نفتح بالفعل أصولًا ، فنحن
بالفعل نؤسس تفاهمًا
من خلال المجتمع بالإضافة إلى أن
الزيارة على الصعيد العالمي أو المحلي
لديها طريقة لتكون كذلك  لديه حساسية
تجاهها بشأن
النصائح التي قدمتها إلى المملكة العربية السعودية
في الماضي ، لكنها بالتأكيد
راسخة في الحاضر وتتطلع إلى
المستقبل
[موسيقى]